according to jung there are four
functions of consciousness or four ego
functions two of them he called rational
functions
and two of them he called irrational or
i would call them non-rational functions
so the two rational functions are
thinking and feeling
which is from a jungian point of view
those are the ways
in which we establish values
and make decisions so feeling maybe a
more subjective orientation to
valuing and decision making but it is
rational
absolutely as rational as uh what we
think of as thinking
and the two non-rational functions are
sensation
and intuition sensation is just what you
think it is
touch sight hearing taste
and hands-on kinds of things of what
needs to be done
right now and intuition is what we're
going to talk about
but they are ways of getting information
they're just not
cognitive so um here we are talking
about
our subjective decision making process
which from a jungian point of view is
feeling and then this way of taking
in information and what we do with it
from an
intuitive place